مساء الخير على حضراتكم اتمنى تكون ليلتكم
وكل ايامكم سعيده باذن الله احنا بقى لنا
فتره ما تقابلناش
الاسئله جت على طول
ما فيش فرصه ان شاء الله نتكلم اثناء البث
يعني
عبد الرحمن
السويفي صديقنا في حلقه هل الدينار
الكويتي اقوى عمله لدي سؤال
هل التضخم او ضعف الصادرات او سعر الفائده
بيضغط على الحكومه الكويتيه لحظه ما شاء
الله الاسئله
هل التضخم او ضعف الصادرات او سعر الفائده
بيضغط على الحكومه الكويتيه من اعباء انا
يعني اذا كنت
يعني اعتقد السؤال في حاجه انت بتسال
حضرتك ان التضخم بيضغط على الحكومه
الكويتيه طبعا التضخم بيضغط على اي دوله
التضخم معناها ان في خلل والخلل ده
المفروض انه ينعكس على سعر قيمه العمله
ولكن لانه الكويت رابطه عملتها اما
بالدولار او بسله عملات يعني في دول واضحه
هذه السعوديه وزي الامارات الى اخره
الكويت بالنسبه لي مش متاكد هي بالدولار
او بسله عملات بس حتى لو كانت سله عملات
هيكون نصيب الدولار فيها هو نصيب الاسد
فهم ياربطه الدينار
بسله العملات او بالدولار وبالتالي هي
بتطلع وبتنزل مع سعر
مع سعر مع سعر الدولار يعني
اذا كنت انا اذا كان حضرتك لك بتسال على
حاجه اعمق من كده يا ريت توضح لي وانا
احاول اجاوب لو اعرف يعني مساء الخير
استاذ سيد جبيل ما هو سبب الجمود في
العلاقات بين العرب وسوريا بعد ان
بعد ان تفائلنا بعودتها لجامعه الدول
العربيه هو حكايه فطور العلاقات ده شيء
طبيعي لانه
[موسيقى]
فكره عوده العلاقات دي معناها ايه معناها
انه مكات العلاقات مقطوعه
وعوده العلاقات معناها نبدا نتكلم مع بعض
لما بنبدا نتكلم على الخلافات لا يعني
اختفائها ولكن بدايه ان احنا نبتدي نناقش
الخلافات اللي كان مفروض يتناقش من 12 سنه
فعوده العلاقات لا يعني انتهاء المشاكل
ولكن يعني البدء في مناقشه المشاكل
وبالمناسبه
من الملفت للنظر يعني انه في دول في حاله
حرب مع بعضها ولا تقطع العلاقات يعني على
سبيل المثال روسيا وامريكا تقريبا هم في
حاله حرب مش رسميا ولكن عمليا ولكن سفير
هنا سفير هناك دول
البلطيق وبولندا اللي هم يعني شديد العداء
لروسيا في تصريحاتهم سفير هنا وسفير هناك
وبالتالي ردا على اسئله حضرتك في توقعات
كثيره من الدول العربيه بمعنى اصح شروط
وفي مطالب من سوريا وبالتالي نتيجه ان
المطالب والشروط كثيره من الجانبين
وتنفيذها ليس سهلا على الجانب السوري على
الاقل
فالمساله طبعا من المطاق ولا على الجانب
العربي لان الجانب العربي علشان يوافق على
المطالب السوريه يصطدم بالفيتو الامريكي
والفيتو الغربي وبالتالي هي رحله صعبه
تبرر لماذا هناك يعني ابصم داونز في
الفتره الحاليه وفي الفتره المقبله
خمسين عام على اعلان الانفتاح الاقتصادي
في مصر عام 74 لماذا لم تتحقق التنميه
الاقتصاديه وهي مده دافيه لدوله لتحقيق
التنميه هل نحن في المسار الخاطئ والله يا
استاذ احمد جمال الاجابه يقينا نحن في
المسار الخاطئ بغض النظر عن التفاصيل
الكثيره لها المسار الخاطئ لانه الامور
بنتائجها بما انه احنا على مدار عشرات
السنوات على الاقل من سنه 74 زي ما انت
حضرتك اشرت كده من بعد انتهاء حرب اكتوبر
ورغبه الرئيس السادات في ان هو يجعل مصر
تتبع اقتصاد السوء او سياسه الانفتاح
الاقتصادي كما تسمى منذ ذلك الوقت ومصر
اما لديها ازمه اقتصاديه او بتحاول العبور
من ازمه اقتصاديه او نجحت في تجاوز ازمه
اقتصاديه وهكذا كان في وثائق نشرتها
منذ عده ايام يعني اسبوعين على الاقصر
يعني بتتكلم على سنه 75
ازمه مشابهه جدا تقريبا للازمه اللي
بتعيشها مصر ازمه اقتصاديه شديده بس طبعا
وقتها كانت الظروف كمان كانت اوضح يعني
احنا خارجين من حرب وبرضو مصر بتحاول تقنع
الدول اجنبيه في ان هي تكلها من عثرتها
والدول ديت لها تصورات وشروط ومنها دول
الخليج اللي بتقول والله انا عاوز اعرف
راسي من رجلي قبل ان اضع ايه استثمارات في
مصر
هل تعتقد ان السياسه هي السبب الرئيسي
لمشاكل الاقتصاد وهل يمكن ربط الاسباب
العميقه لاحمد جمل تاني وهل يمكن ربط
الاسباب العميقه لمشاكل النظام السياسي
بعدم جاهزيتنا للديمقراطيه وما هو الحل هل
يجب ان نبدا من تغيير الثقافه في جزء سهل
في الاجابه يا احمد وفي اجزاء محتاجه بقى
يعني جهود بشر كتير هل المشاكل الاقتصاديه
في مصر وافتح قوسين ودول اخرى مرتبطه
بالسياسه يقينا على الاقل في الحاله
المصريه نعم لانه انت ما تبقاش مرتبطه
بالسياسه ان يكون عندك انت قدرات كبيره
خالص ما عندكش ثروات طبيعيه وعندكش
الثروات بشريه فحتى لو كانت السياسه جيده
الدوله هتبقى فقيره دوله ما عندهاش مقدرات
موقعها سيء ما عندهاش ثروات بشريه ما
عندهاش ثروات طبيعيه فمهما كان الحاكم او
الاداره او جيد يعني برضه هيجد معاناه
بسبب فقر الامكانات الكبيره يعني
او دوله عندها امكانات ولكن اصيبت بحاله
حرب
يعني كبيره جدا والسنوات طويله فمهما بذل
السياسي من مجهود برده يعني هتبقى في
مشاكل نتيجه الظروف اللي بتمر بها انما في
الحاله المصريه اكيد طبعا الاقتصاد
السيء جزء اساسي منه هو السياسه والمساله
دي بالمناسبه مساله متراكمه
وعلي اذا صانع القرار السياسي اتخذ
القرارات السليمه مش هتختفي المشاكل
الاقتصاديه ولكن جزء منها سوف يتبخر من
المهم جدا ان احنا نتذكر المصانع القرار
السياسي ده مش اللي هو بس جمال عبد الناصر
او السادات او حسن مبارك او السيسي او
غيره يعني دول الرؤساء اهم مسؤول في البلد
وعليه يقع العاتق الاكبر لكن ليس وحده دي
قصه معقده وكبيره ومش واحد بس هو اللي معه
العصايه لما بيعمل كويس هو اللي بيعمل كل
حاجه ولما الدنيا بتسوق هو اللي بيعمل
بيلعب دور كبير ولكنه ليس وحيدا وعليه
فردي على سؤال حضرتك نعم السياسه لازم
الاول السياسه تتصلح لازم الامور تبقى
مستقره لازم الدوله تلعب الدور الاساسي
لها في ازاله العقبات امام الاستثمار وهي
العباره اللي بنسمعها منذ ان ولدت على
الاقل الراجل عديت الخمسين ولكن النجاح
فيها محدود جدا
لازم اذا ما كانتش في ديمقراطيه يعني يبقى
على الاقل في مؤسسات بتلعب ادوار واضحه
لانه الصين ما فيش فيها ديمقراطيه ولكن
فيها مؤسسات المؤسسات دي كل مؤسسه بتلعب
دورها بشكل مستقل الى حد كبير وبالتالي
العمليه مش كلها
متمركزه في جهه واحده حزب واحد مش حزب
واحد طبعا الصين في حزب واحد بس حزب الصين
فيه تقريبا 100 مليون انما اقصد مش في جهه
واحده مش في ايد الرئيس او في ايد رئيس
الحكومه بس وعليه ده هيساعد كتير جدا في
انه مشاكل الاقتصاد المصري وغير المصري
تتحل لو عاوز امثله اعطيك من هنا الى ما
شاء الله لكن انت ما طلبتش امس لا الحل
بقى الاجابه موجوده لازم الاول المناخ
يتصلح لازم الدنيا تستقر سياسيا لازم نبقى
عارفين ايه القدراتنا نقدر نعمله ايه اللي
ممكن ناجله لازم
تعمل عمليه موبالايز حشده لكل قدرات هذا
البلد
بتحسين المناخ بس ان انت تخلي الدنيا كل
الناس تشتغل يعني الوقت اللي التشريعات
فيها انا سالت سؤال عشرات هي المهم مش سهل
على شان ما اكون قاعد على كرسي كده وقاعد
بنزر بس حقيقي في حاجات عليه علامات
استفهام ما بتتحلش ابدا يعني لما تقول لي
التعليم في مصر او في دوله المغرب
المسؤول ممكن يستفز لان فعلا في عقبات لما
تقول لي التامين الصحي اقول لك في عقبه
لكن في حاجات ما بتتحلش تقريبا يعني انت
عندك حزم من التشريعات المتضاده
والمتضاربه اللي لو احنا كل سنه بذلنا جهد
بسيط في تنقيط بعض التشريعات اللي بتادي
الى شل الجهاز البروقراطي كله كنا انجزنا
مره واحده في السنه بس ده امر صعب لانه
عمليه التضارب في التشريعات ناتج عن عمليه
تضارب في المصالح وبالتالي في اطراف حريصه
عليه
لما تيجي تسال على حاجه زي قطاع السياحه
اللي انا طرحت عليها عشرات الاسئله قبل
كده ليه احنا
قطاع السياحه بتاعنا يعني بتنافسنا في دول
ليس لديها ابدا ابدا ابدا جزء صغير من
مقدرات مصر تعليمات استفهام عاوزه تطرح
والنسال الله ان يوفق الجميع يعني يوسف
استاذ ما رايكم في دعوه شيخ الاسلام ابن
تيميه والشيخ محمد بن عبد الوهاب رحمهم
الله يا استاذ يوسف
رحم الله من قال لا اعلم
دي عاوزه حد يكون
متخصص في هذا المجال يعني
هل يابان تستقي
من عملتها
هل اليابان تستقي من عملتها المتدنيه
تستفيد من عملتها المتدنيه ده عبد الرحمن
برضو في الصادرات ام الاجور في اليابان
مرتفعه جدا فليست مثل الصين خلينا نجاوب
السؤال بشكل اعمم شويه
حكايه ان اليابان عملتها منخفضه ولا لا
احنا كده بنتكلم على حلقه العملات انت
لازم تقارن العمله يعني
احنا كده بنتكلم على وحده استاذنك ارجع
تاني هل هي عمله اليابان اصلا منخفضه ده
سؤال محتاج يتطرح هي اليابان دلوقتي اظن
هي ايه دولار 130 ين انا مش مش بتابعها من
عده شهور يعني فانت لما تقول منخفضه هي
كانت على مدار السنين 130 وبعدين دلوقتي
مثلا بقت
متين 3400 ما اظنش ان ده حصل العمله
الدوله لكن الاجابه العامه بغض النظر عن
حاله اليابان
يعني ما تنطبقش عليها هذا السؤال ولم تعد
تنطبق تماما على الصين قوي لان هي بدات في
يعني تحرير عملتها الى حد كبير وان كانت
ما زالت متهمه من امريكا ان هي احيانا
بتخفض عملتها انما الدوله بتستفيد من
العمله المخفضه اذا كان لديها ما تصدره
يعني مثلا الصين لما تكون عملتها منخفضه
وعندها جهاز انتاجي ضخم يبقى هي هتصدر
الالم ده
بعمله مخفضه بالعملات الاخرى يبقى القلم
ده لما هيوصل الدول العربيه او هيوصل
اوروبا هيكون سعره منخفض جدا بالنسبه
للعملات المنتجه محليا في الدول الاخرى
والمنافسه لكن اذا هي خفضت العمله وفي نفس
الوقت ليس لديها ما تصدره ولكن لديها
الكثير جدا لتستورده لان هي قدرتها
الانتاجيه المتواضعه زي حال كتير من دولنا
العربيه فطبعا خفض العمله مش هتستفيد منه
حاجه كل اللي هتستفيده في حقيقه الامر ان
هي هتغلي على نفسها الواردات وطبعا لما
اتخفض العمله مش هتخفض العمله بالضبط يعني
لان هي مستفيده ولكن لانها مضطره
مرحبا استاذ سيد وعدتني في الحلقه الماضيه
ان تعطيني اسماء افضل الكتب والمواقع
والقنوات على اليوتيوب لتعليم الاقتصاد
باحترافيه وبالانجليزيه وارجو ايضا ان
تخبرنا عن افضل الكتب الملهمه لك طوال
حياتك طيب هل تاذن لي علشان ده محتاج ان
انا اعمل لست انت عاوز قائمه افضل المواقع
باللغه الانجليزيه او يعني انت عاوز طبعا
لو في بالعربي ماشي بس انا مش عارف لكن
ليه تعليم الاقتصاد وعدي لك قائم حاضر
والله ولكن ده محتاج بس ان انا اعمل لها
كده اعداد جيد واوعدك حاضر لوعد ما زال
قائم وبالمناسبه اذا ربنا احيانا بكره ان
شاء الله
هو احنا بكره هنسجل بس على الاقل هنزيح
حلقه اولى ومعنا باذن الله ضيف جديد ان
شاء الله يكون مفاجاه لكن ان شاء الله
هيجاوب على كتير من اسئلتكم وايضا خلال
هذا الاسبوع اللي هو المقبل بقى باذن الله
البي طلب حضرتك باجابه على افضل المواقع
اللي بتشرح اقتصاد باللغه الانجليزيه
وعليكم السلام لماذا تقوم ده اخونا عبد
الرحمن لحظه
لحظه
الاسئله
هي الاسئله جريت بس ارجع لها تاني فمعلش
مش مقصوده والله انا طلعت كده فوق خالص
عندنا اخونا عرين استاذ سيد كيف فترى وضعه
في المستقبل والله يا اخونا يا ريت تعفيني
من الاجابه على هذا السؤال حتى لا ابدو
متشائرا بس انا قلت الاجابه انه مره تانيه
الدول اللي يعني نصيبها العثر وفي ظروف
سوريا بتقع الوقعه العنيفه دي الحقيقه
بتحتاج اذا كنا متفائلين لسنوات طويله جدا
ان هي ترجع لما كانت عليه قبل 2010 اي
مقارنه بين دولنا وبين الدول القليله اللي
حققت نهضه بعد حروب او يعني
ازمات كبيره زي اليابان زي كوريا الجنوبيه
زي سنغافوره زي الدول دي لها ظروف
استثنائيه وحظيت بدعم كبير جدا جدا من
الولايات المتحده تحديدا والغرب في ظروف
الحرب البارده في ظروف رغبه امريكا ان
تكون هذه الاماكن يعني نقاط
مضيئه لها في مواجهتها مع الاتحاد
السوفيتي لكن هذا لا ينطبق على دوله
ديسوريا وبالتالي ولا ينطبق حتى على دول
اخرى مثلا في العلم العربي اكثر ما يعني
قد يشغل بعض الدول الغربيه او انه الدول
التي تحيط باسرائيل بشكل مباشر لا تنهار
تماما يعني ده ممكن يكون اكثر ما يشغلها
يعني ولا وممكن يسمحوا بانهيارها لو هذا
الانهيار لن ينزاح على الحدود
الاسرائيليه بمعنى ان هم يعني عاملين
اجراءات امنيه تحفظ ابنهم لكن ردا على
سؤالك ما لم يكن لله مشيئه اخرى ونتمنى ان
يكون ذلك سوريا قدامها سنين طويله جدا حتى
تعود الى ما كانت عليه سنه 2010
لدي سؤال هل الاقتصاد المغربي يمكن ان
يصبح اول اقتصاد في افريقيا بسبب ان
المغرب اصبح اولى صناعيه كبرى المغرب ليس
دوله صناعيه كبرى يا صديقي المغرب بلد
عنده بعض الصناعات اللي تميز فيها زي
صناعه السيارات وعنده اقتصاد مفتوح جيد
ولكنه ليس دوله صناعيه كبرى اتمنى طبعا ان
يكون دوله صناعه وكبرى وانه الدوله
الصناعيه الكبرى دي معناها ايه معناها ان
انا عندي تعليم متطور عندي براءات اختراع
كثيره عندي اوراق بحثيه بتسجل فيه اهم
المجلات العلميه العلماء بيسجلوا الابحاث
ديت بتاخدها الشركات عندها قطاع خاص نشط
جدا عندها
قدره على جذب استثمارات بارقام ضخمه فهذا
لا ينطبق الحقيقه على المغرب ان احنا وصف
دوله صناعيه كبرى لكن هي افضل من دول اخرى
كثيره في المنطقه
كيف تقيم وقت كيف تقيم وقف تصدير الحبوب
في اوكرانيا وهل يتسبب ذلك في ازمه غذائيه
للدول مستورده للقمح ده اخونا بدرو
والله احنا لسه في اول يعني قرار روسيا
بعدم تجديد صفقه الحبوب اللي هي ان هي
تسمح به انه
الحبوب الاوكرانيه تخرج وتتحرك بحريه يعني
لسه تاثيره ما بانش ولكن الواضح يعني من
الخبراء اللي بيتكلموا اللي انا بسمع لهم
في هذا المجال انه لو حصلت ازمه في المدى
المنظور هتبقى اقل حده على اساس انه هذه
ليست مفاجاه تماما وانه في دول كثيره بدات
تبحث عن بدائل
السلع اللي بتاتي من اوكرانيا على وجه
التحديد وجزء من اللي بياتي من روسيا لانه
الدنيا مش متوقفه بالنسبه لروسيا يعني
وبالتالي ممكن تبقى في بعض الصعوبات انا
بتكلم على المدى المنظور منكر الامور تسوق
جدا لا قدر اللهزمات لكن الواضح ان الوضع
الان
وفي المستقبل المنظور قد ترتفع الاسعار
لكن لن تكون هناك ازمه حاده على اساس ان
الدول بدات تنوع مصادر
سلعها وبدات تاخذ احتياطات لم تكن قد
اخذتها عند اندلاع الازمه في 2022 وطوال
اخونا
هل تابعت ده كاز هل تابعت جلسه الاستماع
الخاصه بالاجسام المجهوله الهويه الذي
عقدها الكونجرس ما هو رايك حول الحقائق
المثاره لم اتابع هذه الجلسه استاذنك لو
كانت في حاجه
يعني تستحق قولي وانا يعني اعيد قراءتها
تاني يعني لكن انا لم اتابعها الحقيقه
السيد سمعت ان الهيلوكس غير حقيقي وكان
فيلم هندي من اليهود علشان يقنعوا الدول
بالرجوع لارض الميعاد فلسطين هل ده صحيح
الموضوع ده حساس جدا يا ابو ادم وما فيش
حد خالص خالص خالص
لا في الغرب ولا في الشرق بينكر
المذابح التي تعرض لها اليهود في على يد
هتلر واثناء الحرب العالميه الثانيه ولكن
المشككين في الهولوكوست اللي هي العذاب
والمذابح اللي تعرض لها اليهود بيشككوا
بيقولوا حاجتين ان الارقام التي يسوقها
اليهود والمؤيدين لهم مبالغ فيها يعني مش
بينكروا ان هم تعرضوا الى هذه المذابح
وبيضيفوا حاجتين تانيين واحده منها محل
جدل انه ان ما فعل بهم كان من افعال
ايديهم افتح قوسين وهذا لا يليق ابدا لانه
نكل بارقام كبيره جدا من اليهود ليس كل
يهودي هناك كان سياسيا ناشطا ويستحق اذا
كان في بعض اليهود او عدد كبير او قليل
اشتغل ضد مصالح المانيا واراد الالمان
الانتقام منه ينتقموا منه لكن لا يجب ان
يكون هذا الانتقام على الهويه وبيقولوا
حاجه حاجه تالته ولهم حق فيها ان التركيز
على المذابح اللي
تعرض لها اليهود كان لا يقارن ابدا بشعوب
اخرى تعرضت الى مذابح في الحرب العالميه
الاولى والحرب العالميه الثانيه وروسيا
بالمقارنه بالهولوكوست وبيدو امثله كثيره
لكن المثل اللي كان يعني قلقان موجود في
يدهني هو طبعا مذابح الارمن يعني
على سبيل المثال ده الحاجه فانت بتقول مش
صحيح لا هي صحيحه هل مبالغ فيها او لا
مساله محتاجه تدقيق تاريخي كبير فقط لا
غير
وبالمناسبه ما حدش بيقدر يمثل القصه دي
انا اذكر يعني قصه انه انا كنت بشتغل في
جرنان
جرنان مصري وبعدين
مجلس التحرير واحنا قاعدين اقترحوا انه
نعمل حاجه عن الهولوكوست وطلب مني انا
اقوم بالجانب اللي انا اقدر اقوم به وهو
ان انا
يعني اتكلم على
يعني حقيقه الهولوكوست والمشككين فيها
ورايتهم من المؤرخين
الغربيين وهكذا انما رغم انه الفكره كانت
المفروض يعني ان ما فيش فيها مشكله على
الاقل بالنسبه لقانون البلد اللي احنا كنا
موجودين فيه ومصر ما فيش ما يمنع ومع ذلك
فشلت المساله فشل ذريع لانه اكتشفنا انه
واحد انا الناس اللي حبيت اتكلم معاهم لم
اجد الا مؤرخ واحد وابعث لي حوالي ثلاث
اربع الاف كلمه وكان بالغ التحفظ هو كان
بيشكك في الهولوكوست بس بالمعنى اللي انا
قلته مش ان ما فيش
وكلاف كده لم اجد اي حد تاني يتحدث بسهوله
يعني ما حدش بيتحدد بسهوله بمعنى انه فيما
يتعلق بانكار الهولوكوستا ما هو لو قال
الهولوكوست يبقى هو هيضيف قصه جديده من
مئات الالاف القصص اللي ذكرت في الدراما
وفي الكتب ثم انه الزملاء الاخرين اللي
اشتغلوا على ملفات اخرى وجدوا صعوبه
واكتشفوا ان هم اذا هم اصروا انه يمشوا في
هذا الملف قد يجد صعوبات وملاحقات لاحقا
يعني اذا ارادوا الانتقال والسفر الى بلاد
بتجرب التشكيك في الهولوكوست طيب السلام
عليكم استاذ سيد ارجو ان تتحدث عن الوضع
في ليبيا وعلى الاقتصاد الليبي وهل ستشهد
استقرار في الوضع الليبي والله نامل هذا
احنا بنسمع حكايه يعني محاوله الاطراف
المختلفه للبحث عن استقرار في ليبيا من من
سنوات ولكن ليبيا زي ما قلت لحضرتك قبل
كده
يعني بلد مش مستعجل على مساله الاصلاح ولا
الاستقرار النخب بتاعته مش مستعجله لانه
زي الارض بتدفع والجيوب والافواه بتبلع من
اموال النفط الليبي ده بالنسبه للنخب
والامراء الحرب اللي موجودين هناك وكل
واحد بيحارب على المزيد فما فيش حاجه ماسه
والشركات الاجنبيه المستفيده والدول
الكبيره محافظه على مصالحها ويعني الامور
ماشيه ما فيش مشاكل فمش مستعجلين قوي هم
على اللي هي اساسها الليبيين اللي هم
يلاقوا حل لانه مش لاقيين توافق التوافق
يعني هينفع حد وهيضر حد في اللي هيتضر مش
عاوزه وبالتالي الحرب مكمله بتمويل ليبي
خالص ما فيش فيه مشاكل يعني
السلام عليكم ارجو ان تتحدى هل تابعت الى
اجبت هل تتفق مع
ان خلاص العالم في التخلص من الدولار
وتوابعه في راي المتواضع انه الحل الوحيد
لكنه مثل العلاج الكيماوي
هو يعني حكايه انه
انه العالم يتخلص من الدولار هيتخلص من
الدولار ازاي انت كلمه الدولار بيعبر الى
حد كبير جدا عن حاجتين الوضع الاقتصادي
ونصيب الولايات المتحده من التجاره
الدوليه اللي هي الحاجات اللي بتتاخد في
الكتب واحد اتنين تلاته ودي بغض النظر عن
النفوذ الامريكي هيخلي الدولار عمله
رئيسيه مهيمنه وان كانت ليست بهذه الهيمنه
لان في دول تانيه زي الصين بقى عندها
نصيبه في التجاره الدوليه اكبر فيفترض انه
يكون وضع اليوان اكبر لكن ده مش كل القصه
في حاجات تانيه ان اليوان لم يستوفي
الشروط
الواجبه علشان تبقى عمله احتياط عمله
الاحتياط لها شروط وبتفرض
مطالب معينه على البنك المركزي للدوله
صاحبه عمله الاحتياط شاشه شفافيه كبيره
عمليه تحرير كامل للعمله قدره الناس خارج
الصين ان هم يحصلوا على العمله ويتم
تداولها وقبلها قصه طويله وبنك المركزي
هناك بياخد هذا الاعتبار ويتيح الارقام
الى اخره قصه كبيره يعني مش سهله الحاجه
التانيه النفوذ الامريكي اللي هو بيضاعف
من اهميه الدولار اكثر من حقيقه حجمه
مساهمه الولايات المتحده في التجاره
الدوليه
فحكلتنا نتخلص من الدولار هو ليس قرارا
اداريا يؤخذ ولكن ده بيعبر عن الوضع
الاقتصادي والسياسي للولايات المتحده ما
سوف يحدث وليس قرارات اداريه ولكن عمليه
اسلولي بتشور لبطيئه ولكنها قادمه في
الطريق انه
مع وجود قوى اخرى بتسعى ان هي تاخذ مكانها
تحت الشمس زي ما كان الالمان بيقولوا قبل
الحرب العالميه التانيه بديهي انه تدريجيا
الناس بتروح لليوان الناس بتعمل اول عملات
الاخرى يعني الناس بيعملوا تبادل بالعملات
المحليه الناس بتخفف من استثماراتها في
السوق الامريكي هو انت مش ملاحظ مثلا كل
الوقت طول الوقت على على مستوى المنطقه
العربيه ان دول الخليج بتكثف من
استثماراتها في الصين وفي الهند على سبيل
المثال طب ده معناه ايه كل استثمار
خليجي راح للهند وللصين هو الحقيقه كان
يمكن ان يذهب البديل لي ما كانش مثلا
ما كانش هيبقى في الاردن وفي مصر يعني ده
هتاخد ارقام بسيطه ولكن كان هيبقى في
الغرب فده معناها انه الكفه القاسيه
بتزداد ثقلا وبالتالي بلد زي الجزائر مش
بس ان هو قدم على عضويه البريكس رسميا
ولكن كمان شارك فيه عضويه البنك بنك
التنميه التابع الاسيوي وقال انا مستعد
اشارك به مليار ونص مليار كل الاستثمارات
وكل المشروعات التي تبرم بين الجزائر وهي
دوله ذات اقتصاد جيد لا يكون خصما طبعا من
استثمارات كان الغرب يمكن ان يضخها في
الجزائر وهكذا
استاذ سيد لازم تعمل برنامج تدلنا فيه على
كتب ومراجع منهجيه لرفع الوعي السياسي ده
ممكن يكون في نفس الحلقه اللي بنتكلم فيها
على
مراجع سياسيه
حاضر
ابدل جهد ان شاء الله
بلاش تكرر في الشات يعني مش عارف الله يا
خالد يعني ايه يعني ايه يا عمرو بلاش اكرر
في الشد
ار
برد على نقل ابدا طيب ماشي الحرب في
السودان برايك يا استاذ ماذا تتوقع ان
تكون نهايه الحرب في السودان وفي توقعك
متى يمكن ان يتحقق ذلك
الواضح في السودان انه الناس السودانيين
والناس اللي هم يعني كانوا اساتذه كبار في
الشان السوداني والله هذا حقيقي يعني في
اول يوم اندلع وتاني يوم كان معظم من
اكلمهم بيقول لي اديني تلات ايام او اربع
ايام اسبوع على الاكثر وسوف يكون قد انتهى
امر الدعم السريع وبصدق والله انا لم اصدق
كلمه واحده مما سمعت من كثره ما شاهدت من
نزاعات يتخيل اطرافها او مراقبيها ان
النزاع سوف ينتهي خلال ايام حكايه النزال
ينتهي خلال الايام ده تقريبا تبخر في
التاريخ وانتهى ما فيش يعني جيش بيروح
يطلع بجيش بالصيف ويخلص على جيشه او حتى
في الحرب العالميه الاولى او الثانيه بعد
ثلاث اربع سنين يحصل عمليه استسلام
الحاجات دي واضح ان هي انتهت في التاريخ
واحنا بقينا في عصر الصراعات المفتوحه
يؤسفني ان الوضع في السودان بالغ بالغ
السوء انا بقول لبعض الشباب اللي بيسالني
اللي مش قادر يتخيل تخيل ان انت في مدينه
زي القاهره لا قدر الله او الرباط او
الجزائر انه اي مدينه يعني
انه المدافع دي مش بتضرب في منطقه حدوديه
ده في قلب المباني بين الناس جريمه يعني
يعني غريبه الشكل
يعني من الامور المؤسفه انه حتى
الفيديوهات اللي بيجيبوها ليه القاده
العسكريه للطرفين دايما اجواء احتفاليه
وكان هم خلصوا السودان يعني من عدو خارجي
كان جاسم على صدورهم بتعبر عن فرحه يعني
في غير محلها وتهليل وعلامات والله اكبر
والراس
نسال الله ان هو يصلح لهم الحال يعني
الحرب
في السودان اجبت استاذ سيد لازم نعمل
برنامج ايوه جابت كيف تقيم وقت اجبت استاذ
السيد لدي سؤال
سمعت اجبت
عبد الله
هل تعتقد يا دكتور انه حان الوقت لتغيير
الدماء انا سيد انا صحفي ولست دكتور ده
للتوضيح الاول حان الوقت لتغيير الدماء اي
دماء يا صديقي عن اي بلد
انما مشي يعني بصفه عامه تغيير الدماء من
وقت لاخر في اي بلد جيد يعني ملخص مشاكل
مصر كلها كلمتين سوق اداره وفساد يؤدي لكل
النتائج الكارثيه ماشي يا وسام هل تابعت
اجبت
السيد هل لديه سؤال هل الاقتصاد اجبت
الحرب في
والاسئله بتتكرر كتير طب ما انت يا خالد
خلاص ما انت بتقول لي ما تكررش الاسئله
وانت بتكرر التعليق كتير انا خلاص شفت
سؤالك والله بلاش تكرر في الشات فخلاص انا
فهمت
اكرم استاذ سيد
نفس الاسئله مكرره
طيب ماجد بيقول ما رايك بما تقوم به
السعوديه من تغيرات بكل المجالات ورؤيتها
الالفيه ل 30/2020 والله ما يبدو لي لان
في ارقام لا تتوفر الي ما يبدو لي امر جيد
جدا هذا ما كان يطلبه الكثير من السعوديين
انه ما يكونش السعوديه تعتمد فقط على
البترول والغاز وعلى السياحه الدينيه
او على صناعه يعني
او على الامور اللي هي الثابته اللي
اشتهرت بها السعوديه دايما وان السعوديه
تبقى بلد زي كل البلدان تبقى عندها صناعه
والزراعه والسياحه وهكذا فما يحدث جيد جدا
لا شك يعني مدى قدرتهم بقى على الاستمرار
في النجاح ده هيعتمد على يعني ادارتهم لكل
المشروعات والتغيرات والتحديات اللي بتمر
بها المنطقه انما بداوا هذا جيد
من سوريا حلب ارين اهلا وسهلا لدي
سلافا ارى الاستثمار في البنت التحتيه في
دول تستورد غذائها يعتبر خطا استراتيجي
الاستثمار يمر عبر مراحل اولا يلزم
الاكتفاء وعدم التبعيه في الغذاء وهذه
مشكله كل الدول العربيه هو في سوء فهم
مساله البنيه التحتدي اخونا او فيها جزء
يعني
ما هي البنيه التحتيه يعني اللي المفروض
الدول تستثمر فيها بنيه تحديد حاجات حيويه
جدا بدونها لا توجد حياه ولا يوجد اقتصاد
تقريبا البنيه التحتيه لان في ناس بتستخف
بالمساله يقول لك كباري يعني لا البنيه
التحتيه ما هياش كباري البنيه التحتيه دي
معناها
شبكه طرق وشبكه الطرق هي واحده من اهم
اساسيات بناء اي حضاره لان ما فيش حد
بينتقل من بيته الى عمله الى سفره الا عبر
الطريق وما فيش ازدهار في منطقه بدءا من
مصيف الى مصنع الا لما بيكون في طريق يؤدي
الى المنطقه هتروح فين اذا ما كانش في
طريق شبكه طرق بكل بقى تفريعاتها طرق يعني
كباري مش عارف ايه انفاق كل الكلام ده
انما كمان في شبكات ميه في شبكات كهرباء
في شبكات غاز في مطارات
في في كتير يعني في موانئ ما فيش حاجه هتم
فيه شبكه نقل داخلي اذا كان بري يعني على
الطرقات او سكك حديديه او الطيران قصه
كبيره وبالتالي والبنيه التحتيه بتدخل
فيها المستشفيات والمدارس هي يعني حسب
الاقتصاد في اي اقتصاد هيجي هو محتاج ده
مش هيبقى فيه اقتصاد بدون طرق وبدون مياه
وبدون كهرباء الى اخره انما هو القصه اللي
انت بتقول عليها وطبعا مثلا كل البنيه
اللي مرتبطه بالسياحه من فنادق
واماكن للترفيه الى اخره انما اللي انت
بتقول عليه واللي هو مش محل الخلافه بس
بدون مبالغه انه انت يعني بتشير الى بعض
الحالات زي الحاله المصريه انه كان في
انفاق كبير على البنيه التحتيه ايوه هو بس
محل الخلاف انه
قد ايه بعض هذه المشروعات وهي كلها او
معظمها يعني مشروعاته ليس محل شكي كان
يمكن تاجيله بحيث انه ما يكونش في تراكم
في المديونيه
قد تجد الدوله صعوبه في سداده هو بتتكلم
على الاولويات مش على اهميه البنيه
التحتيه كفكره عامه لكن بدون بنيه تحتيها
ما فيش اقتصاد يعني
يعني حتى لما انت تتكلم من المصانع تنتج
ايوه المصانع تنتج ما هو مصنع عشان ينتج
ده محتاج محطه كهرباء ومحتاج طريق ومحتاج
ميه
ومحتاج شبكه مواصلات الى اخره يعني
السيد انا اسمي علي طالب بالكليه الطب
عايز عاوز انغمس في السياسه لاني احبها ما
هي مصادري من كتب واعلام مرئي ومقروء عربي
وغرب المصادر كثيره ومش عارف ابدا منين
وازاي يا اننا ميسي اه انت كاتب علي يا
دكتور علي ان شاء الله تبقى دكتور عظيم
يعني
اولا الكليات الطب
وقدمت كثير من السياسيين يعني للعالم
انت علشان عاوز تبدا ما عليك الا ان تبدا
بدون مش لازم تبقى خطه يعني تبدا من الالف
الى الياء انت حضرتك والناس اللي بيسالوا
عن فهم مراجع السياسه والتعليم لغايه ما
بيتكلموا على اسماء مراجع معينه اول شيء
عليك ان تعرف لغه اجنبيه اذا لم تعرف لغه
اجنبيه فلا تتوقع ان تحقق شيء يذكر في
دراسه اي علم من العلوم انت طالب طب وعارف
لو انت مش بتعرف انجليزي مش هتقدر تدرس طب
اللغه الاجنبيه دي ايه الحد الادنى هي
اللغه الانجليزيه انما في لغات اخرى اوكي
فانت لازم تعرف الاول لغه اجنبيه اذا
اتقنت لغه اجنبيه ده هيمكنك من انت لانه
المساله مثلا مثلا في الانجليزي مش ان انت
تعرف الكلام اللي بيقوله الامريكان انت
تعرف كل الكلام القيم الذي يقال بكل
اللغات مترجمه الى اللغه الانجليزيه
واللغات الاخرى المهمه زي الفرنساوي
والالماني والصيني والروسى انما للاسف
الشديد المحتوى باللغه العربيه متواضع جدا
جدا جدا بحيث لا يقيموا اودن يعني ما
تقدرش ان انت تعتمد عليه اعتماد كبير على
اي حاجه على اي حاجه ان شاء الله نتمنى ان
ده يتغير لكن حتى يتغير كل اللي عاوز يعرف
اقتصاد واللي عاوز يعرف سياسه واللي عاوز
يعرف اي حاجه تانيه عليها ان يجد لغه
اجنبيه ان انت بدات باجابه لغه اجنبيه
هتجد نفسك انت مع الوقت بتحصل عمليه فرز
يعني بتقرا حاجات بتلاقي ان الكلام ده
بالوقت بتلاقيه كلام فارغ طبعا في اصلا
مصادر كبيره يعني انت لما هتخش على
المصادر الكبيره ديت
مره لما انا كنت بقول انه في
من ممكن في اخر مره تقابلنا كان في خمسه
خمسه يوليو اللي فات لما اتكلمت على انه
احنا لازم نكون شاكرين ومهتمين به مصادر
غربيه كبيره
والمصادر المختلفه ديت في حد قال لي دي
ناس بتضلل طبعا بيضللوا وانا قلت ان هم من
الجنه اولا دي اصدارات كبيره جدا
كتير يعني لكن المصادر ديت ايوه عندها
اجندات وايوه احيانا بتضلل واي احيانا كل
ده موجود لان احنا مش في الجنه يعني مش في
عالم مثالي ولكن على الرغم من كل سوءاتها
اولا هي لا تعبر ما فيش فيها صوت واحد
يعني انت لما تاخد الاقامه بالسلامه لما
تاخد نيويورك لما تاخد
هتجد في نفس الجرنان مثلا في قضيه كبيره
زي زي مثلا حرب الروسيه هتجد ان غالبيه
الجرنان واخد
موقف وجهه نظر الغرب واحيانا بشكل صادق
انما لن تعدم ابدا انك تجد اربع خمس كتاب
بيقولوا كلام مستقل ولا احد يعني يعني
يسقطهم
هتجد انت مع الوقت عمليه فرز طبيعي
للمصادر المحترمه اللي انت بتروح لها من
كاتب لكاتب بس اقرا الاول كل يوم هتتابع
الشان ومتابعه الشان هتلاقي نفسك مصدر
بيقودك الى مصدر وهكذا
عجبنا
وسام
اكرم انت مغربي معرفش بيقول على مين
لدي سؤال هل الاقتصادي كيف ترى اجبت ارى
ان الاستثمار في البنت تحتيه اجابنا هل
تابعت اعجابنا
ما هو رايك في زياره هنيه لتركيا علما وان
نتنياهو هزور تركيا بعد كم يوم
وساطه جديده
انا ما كنتش اعرف ان هنيه ريحه يعني علشان
ما اعلقش على حاجه لا اعلمها بس ايه صح
الخبر زي ما انت بتقوله وانه الاتنين
هيكون في زياره من رئيس وزراء اسرائيل
وشخصيه مهمه في حماس فقطعا قطعا هيكون
محاوله من تركيا ان هم يقربوا المسافات في
بعض القضايا ملهاش اي تفسير اخر يعني
السيد لدي سؤال يعني مفاوضات غير مباشره
بين الطرفين
لحل بعض القضايا بعض القضايا اللي هي يعني
يوميه يعني مش مش عمليه
سلام ولا غيره يعني مش حاجه كبيره يعني
كيف
تحلل مستقبل النظام الجزائري الحالي ده
سؤال كبير قوي يا صديقي
استاذ سيد لدي سؤال على الاقتصاد ما تخلي
السؤال مثلا لو تجزؤوا شويه يكون ابسط لان
كلمه النظام الغذائي نظام الكبائر الموجود
الحانه رئيس تبوها حكومته هي امتداده
لنفسه النظام اساسا يحكم الجزائر منذ يعني
حرب التحرير
وفي محاولات لتغيير يعني بطيء في الجزائر
في انه يعني يبداوا يعملوا عندهم اقتصاد
مفتوح ويكتذبوا استثمارات
اجنبيه ده كان قليل قوي في الجزائر ويكون
فيه خير في غير قطاع البترول والغاز
وانه يعني بعد فتره الركود الكبيره اللي
كانت مرتبطه بحاله الجنود اللي ارتبط بمرض
الرئيس بوتفليقه بقى الجزائر اكثر نشاطا
في المنطقه يعني وخارجها
فلو يبقى السؤال محدد شويه يبقى كتر خيرك
هل تابعت جلسه تاني الحرب في السوق
هل هناك مشكله اقتصاديه ولا احنا داخلين
على دوله جديده تقوم على الغاء الدعم على
المواطنين والتشجيع اصحاب رؤوس الاموال
احمد منير
هل هناك انت بتتكلم على ايه بقى يعني
بتتكلم على مصر مثلا مصر عندها مشكله
اقتصاديه طبعا اما حكايه الغاء الدعم
وتشجيع رؤوس الاموال هي دي الوصفه اللي
بتقدمها الصندوق النقد لكل الدول اللي
عندها ازمه مشابهه لمصر فالاثنين مرتبطين
لولا ان مصر عندها ازمه اقتصاديه مش تروح
للصندوق والصندوق مش هيوصلها بان هي لازم
تلغي الدعم اه يعني كله مرتبط بكله
هل تعتقد انه حان الوقت استاذ سيد لدي
يا اكرم السؤال ارهقتني بكثير جدا انت
كررت وبعض الناس حوالي 15-20 مره فرجاء
انا ما بعرفش اشوف بقيه الاسئله فالناس
اللي هي حابه سؤال انا لو انت حريص على
الاجابه مش هتستفيد كتير ان انت تكرره 15
20 مره مريض جدا يعني
حتى عشان اعرف اشوف بقت الاسئله يعني سؤال
الحرب في السودان سؤال الاقتصاد المغربي
سؤال تاني متكرر كتير جدا عدد مهول من
المرات
السلام عليكم ما رايك بالفوضى ده وجدي
هل مراكب الفوضى التي نعيشها في كل العالم
وهل هي بالاتجاه الى التفاقم والهدوء لا
الفوضى اللي بيعيشها العالم اولا هو
العالم بصفه عامه علشان يكون الكلام
يعني واضح
ما يعني العالم
يعني الصراع دايما موجود يعني الاساس في
العلاقات الدوليه هي الصراعه
انما في فترات بتبقى اكثر هدوءا من فترات
اخرى يعني في الفتره من واحد وتعين 92 ل
2015 و18 كانت فتره اكثر هدوءا بكثير من
السنوات اللي احنا بدانا نعيشها من اول
كورونا والحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه انت
بتسال على
هل العالم سبب الفوضى ده احنا عاملين
الحمد لله ثلاث اربع حلقات من فتره طويله
كنا بنتكلم فيهم على استشراف الوقت الحالي
والمستقبل وخلاصه الحلقات اللي حضرتك تكون
تابعتها او لا انه احنا الخلاصه كلها
بنعيش فتره انتقاليه اللي انا اتكلمت
عليها بكلمه او فتره انتقاليه ما بين نظام
عالمي بيتداعم
نظام العالم اللي كانت الولايات المتحده
فيه بتسيطر فيها على كل مقدرات العالم
يعني بدون منازع ونظام عالمي دول بتحاول
تقول لن تكوني انت وحدك على يعني قمه
العالم وتحكمي وفقا لهواكي احنا كمان
عاوزين يكون لنا مكان دول زي مين زي كل
دول البريكس زي الهند زي البرازيل زي جنوب
افريقيا زي الصين زي زي روسيا زي الدول
العربيه بالمناسبه اللي رغم ان بعضها في
وضع جيد وبعضها في وضع مش جيد لكن هي كمان
غير راقبه غير راغبه في ان هي تعيش
تحت عباءه الدول الغربيه عاوز تاخد كمثال
ودي حاجه يعني يعني احنا دايما بنتكلم على
حاجات سلبيه بس من الحاجات الايجابيه اللي
توبع يعني
اللي تبعت على نفسك البهجه شوف مواقف
الدول العربيه في التعامل مع القوى
الكبيره هتجد الدول العربيه تغيرت تماما
على صوره النبطيه اللي موجوده في اذهان
الناس يعني انت عندك النهارده الجزائر
والمغرب بيلعبوا
بخشونه مع الدول الاوروبيه الكبيره كل
واحده بتستخدم اوراق ضغط عنيف مع الدول
الكبيره وتعاقبهم احيانا اذا خرجوا او
خرجوا عن الخط عندك الدول الخارجيه بتفعل
نفس الشيء فانت عندك في تغير يعني
اخونا
مش لاقي الاسم لكن السلام عليكم معك
السلام عليكم معك عيد من السعوديه هل رؤيه
2030 السعوديه تسير بالطريق الصحيح وما
رايك فيها هو سؤال محتاج انه تدقيق اكتر
لكن الاجابه السريعه اللي ممكن تتقال في
اجابه عابره انه عشرين ثلاثين جوهرها ايه
جوهرها هو نفس جوهر مجموعه من الخطط اللي
اعلنت عنها السعوديه واعلنت عنها الكويت
والامارات على مدار 30 40 سنه هو الانتقال
من الاعتماد شبه الكلي على عوائد البترول
والغاز يا استاذ عيد
الى مصادر اخرى ما اراءنا بالملاحظه
المباشره غير المدققه ان هذا الانتقال بدا
ياخذ جديه لم نلاحظها في عشرات السنين
الماضيه بدا السعوديين حريصين جدا على
تطوير قطاعات اخرى ايه القطاعات الاخرى
تقريبا كل القطاعات الاخرى عاوزين يجيبوا
جامعات كبيره تبقى على السعوديه عاوزين
يجيبوا مؤسسات ترفيهيه عاوزين الدوري
السعودي
ويبقى دوري بيتشافوا ممكن يتشفر لاحقا
عاوزين يجيبوا
غير قطاع الترفيه كله عاوزين يجيبوا يبقى
السعوديه مقر لكل الشركات الكبيره في
العالم عاوزين يبقى عندهم موانئ عاوزين
يبقى عندهم فهذه بدايات عايزين قوه نوويه
عاوزين يبقى عندهم اكتفاء في التصنيع
ما في شك ما في شك ان هذا افضل بكثير جدا
مما كان اما نجاح هذا من عدمه طبعا انت
هتاخد بقى تخش في التفاصيل بعض المشروعات
ربما كانت جيده بعضهم غير لا بعضهم انفق
عليه اكثر دي تفاصيل لكن
الاجابه التي تبدو لي انا انه نعم هناك
سير في الاتجاه الصحيح في هذا المجال
هل تابعت
اخونا عبد
عبود بيقول لماذا الفقر منتشر في العالم
بشكل فظيعي هل السبب الراسماليه اما وارد
الارض لا تكفي احتياجات الناس والله ده
سؤال يعني يعني ما فيش اجابه مختصر عليه
وانما الدول اللي هي فقيره جزء منها طبعا
ان هي بتكون ضحيه صراعات دول كبيره انما
هي برضو مسؤوله عن هذا يعني انت في دول
ما هو انت علشان الدوله بتتطور دوله ما
بتتطورش بانه بالامنيات الطيبه بس وان
الناسنا يعني الشعوب اللي اتطورت عانت
كثيرا حتى تتطور فانت عاوز تاخد دول
اوروبا كلها دول اوروبا عاشت عشرات
السنوات من الحروب والثورات والمحاولات
والضحايا علشان دول تستقر وتبقى في الوضع
اللي هي فيه وطبعا جزء منه نهب للشعوب
العالم الاخرى بس دي قصه تانيه وبالتالي
عانت كثيرا وعليه فانه انت بتقول الفقره
منتشر الفقره منتشر نعم الفقر منتشر لانه
سوء فيه يعني يعني سياسات هذه الدول جزء
منها وليس تفصيل العالم الخارجي وحده
بتتكلم على الموارد الموارد
ما زالت رغم انه في نظريه مشهوره اسمها
الجولدن بيلين نظريه المليار الذهبي وهي
نظريه مشهوره عند الروس ولكنها موجوده عند
العالم العربي من غير ما نعرف اسمها وهو
انه في قناعه عند العالم وعند النخب انه
موارد الارض تكفي مليار واحد بس والمليار
ده يفضل ان يكون هو المليار المسيطر اللي
موجود في الولايات المتحده والغرب عشان هو
يفضل سعيد ومبسوط عليه ان ينهب مواهر
موارد الدول الاخرى لانه قناعتهم من
الموارد لن تكفي الى الابد ولكن هذا كلام
مردود عليه انه الموارد حتى هذه اللحظه
ليست هي السبب الرئيسي في فقر الناس وانما
اداره الموارد هو السبب الرئيسي في ذلك
عاوز كمثال هل يتخيل حد انه السودان
السودان بكل امكاناته ممكن يكون بيعاني من
نقص في الغذاء هل يصدق احد ان بلد زي
اثيوبيا بالكم المهول من المياه يبقى عنده
فقر في المياه لانه مش قادر يستفيد منها
فالمشكله مش في المورد ولكن في اداره
المورد
عندي استفسار بخصوص رؤيه حضرتك للعلاقه مع
ايران الا ترى ان خطر التغول الايراني عن
طريق المد الشيعي الطائفي خطر حقيقي خصوصا
بالنظر لسلسله ايراني العدوانيه التي اتت
لتفجير الوضع في كل الدول طب انت يعني
الاسئله اخونا عمرو مبني على وجهه نظر
مسبقه انه ايران دي دوله
اولا قبل ما اجاوب على سؤالك في سوء فهم
سوء فهم القائم على ان انا بدافع عن ايران
انا غير معني بالدفاع عن ايران ولا غير
ايران دفع عن ايران ليه يعني
انا كل اللي كنت معني به من سنوات ان انا
بقول انه في تناقضات يعني في خلافات بين
ايران وبين دول مختلفه منها بعض الدول
العربيه التناقضات دي حلها التواصل مع
ايران
والمواجهه الايجابيه المواجهه الايجابيه
يعني ان انت بتزود قوتك وقدرتك على
المواجهه وفي نفس الوقت دايما في حوار
انما مش الحل بان انا ادخل في حاله حرب
وقطيعه واقطع العلاقات لانه انت ايران لن
تختفي من على الخريطه وبما انها لن تختفي
على الخريطه وبما ان قدرك ان انت تكون
دوله عربيه
مجاوره لايران وربما يكون بعض الدول اضعف
من ايران
فانت عليك ان تتعامل معها ولا حيله لك في
ذلك ما فيش حيله لاوكرانيا فانها تتعامل
مع روسيا ما فيش حيله مع بوتان ان هي
تتعامل مع الصين ما فيش حيله للمكسيك انها
تتعامل مع الولايات المتحده وبالتالي ده
قدر الجغرافيا علينا ان نتعامل تتعامل
ازاي بقى قادر ان انت تزود قدرتك على
القوه وانك تبقى قادر يكون احسن واحسن مش
قادر عليك ان تتفاهم معها بقدر الامكان
زود حلفائك بس بلاش قطع العلاقات وانك انت
تشيطن ايران وتصورها على انها اسوا بلد في
العالم لا ايران بلد زي اي بلد له وعليه
في ناس معتدله وفي ناس متشدده وعليك ان
انت تفتح جذور التفاهم افضل لك من ان
تغلقه لا اكثر ولا اقل وحكايه التشيع ده
موضوع بصراحه يعني يعني
موضوع تم المبالغه فيه كثيرا جدا جدا جدا
جدا جدا جدا جدا يعني ولاسباب سياسيه
معروفه واستفادت منها دول كبيره يعني
اعتقد ان مشكله مصر ليس بالكفاءات او
الثروات وانما بالتكاثر السكاني الغير
مسيطر عليه وهو ما يستنزف كل شيء في البلد
والله فيه وفيه يعني في مشاكل في عمليه
الاداره وفي مشاكل زياده سكانيه هو خليط
من مشكلات كثيره يا صديقي العزيز يعني
ارى ان الاستثمار اجبنا هل تابعت اجابنا
كيف تقيم هل تابعت هل عندكم في المغرب
تعبدون
عزيزي هل تابعت جلسه اعجبنا
ابو ادم استاذنا العزيز
ده محمد
لا انا اسف انا جبت غلط محمد عبد الجبار
استاذنا العزيز الحرب في السودان في رايك
يا استاذ ماذا تتوقع ان تكون نهايه الحرب
لا ما انا اجبت حضرتك اتوقع نهايه الحرب
لا مش عارف ما عنديش توقع لنقل الحرب انا
شايف ان الوضع
اذا لم يتم السيطره عليه فاري فارسون
باسرع وقت ممكن هتاخد نفس السيكل الشريره
اللي جت في السودان وفي دول اخرى لانه حتى
الان احنا بنتكلم على حرب حتى الان رغم كل
الخساير الكبيره حوالي 1500 يعني قتيل
وطبعا ارقام ضخمه من الجرحى وتدمير للبنيه
التحتيه والاقتصاد السوداني الهشه اصلا
حتى الان الامر يمكن السيطره عليه لانه ما
اخدش ابعاد طائفيه وقبليه وعرقيه في
السودان لرسائل وضع اكتر من كده هيبقى
الوضع تتحول الى حرب اهليه شامله ولا قدر
الله لن تستطيع السيطره عليها لانه
بالضروره كل ما طال الوقت هتخش اطراف
محليه اخرى الاطراف المحليه دي لازم
هتستعين بصديق من الخارج ويعيش السودان
كابوتا نسال الله انه
يرحمه منه يعني
كيف تقيم وانت
كيف تقيم وقف تصدير الحبوب في اوكرانيا
وهل يتسبب ذلك في ازمه غذاء للدول
المستورده اجابنا
اخونا كاز انا لم اتابع الجلسه
فخلاص انا هتابعك بس خلاص استاذنك ما
تكررش السؤال تاني واوعدك ان انا هتابعه
والله لو في جديد هقول لك عليه بس عشان
اعرف اجاوب بقت اسئله الناس
استاذ سيد ما شاء الله انت مرجع في الشؤون
السياسيه ده ابو رياض
استفدت منك كثيرا واتعلمت اقتصاد منك انت
والدكتور هاني ربنا يخليك ويسعدك وان شاء
الله عندنا انا بس كان لظروف يعني يطول
شرحها انا لا احب ان اشغل الناس يعني
بالامور الشخصيه ولكن يعني نقدر نقول كان
في فتره بس ما قدرناش ان احنا اللي هي
الاسابيع الماضيه ظروف دفعتنا انه يكون
عدد الحلقات قليل لكن ان شاء الله بفضل
الله هنرجع تاني لنفس معدلنا من عدد
الحلقات
اللي كنتم معتدين عليه وان شاء الله تنتعش
الامور سواء في اقتصاد نعرف او في اقتصاد
الام يعني
كيف
نريد الحديث عن بلدي سوريا كيف ترى الوضع
اجبت يا اخونا
هل يجب ان يكون مع السلطه الخوف من العقاب
لكي يصبح لكي لكي لا يصبح هناك طغاه
بديهي من امن العقاب اساء الادب يعني اي
حد اي حد مسؤول صغير او كبير اذا ما كانش
عليه اي رقاب
ابسلوت باور ازود يعني السلطه المطلقه
مفسده مطلقه ده طبيعي
انا عاوز اقول لكم على حاجه يعني بمناسبه
القصه ديت
انا لفت نظري حاجه احنا اتكلمنا على
الازمه اللي موجوده في اسرائيل
ومشاكل نتنياهو اللي عاوز يعمل تغيير في
النظام القضائي للاسباب الكثيره اللي احنا
تحدثنا عليها وده يعني مش موضوعنا دلوقتي
ولكن في حلقتين بيتكلموا عن الازمه في
اسرائيل وبالمناسبه ده موضوع المفروض يحسب
اهتمام المهتم بالشان العام انما اللي لفت
نظري جدا حاجتين في الاسبوع اللي فاتوا
عشان تعرفوا قوه
المؤسسات المستقره
تسمي اسرائيل دوله تسميها كيان تكرهها
تحبها انتم عارفين موقفي من اسرائيل وانا
بقوله كل يوم
ولكن بقطع النظر عن مشاعرك تجاهها
فانت عشان تعرف قوه يعني ايه دوله عندها
مؤسسات مستقره وعندها ديمقراطيه رئيس
وزراء اسرائيل
بيصاب بتعب صحي بينقل الى المستشفى بشكل
مفاجئ في وسط ازمه عنيفه الازمه العنيفه
ديت غير مسبوقه في اسرائيل يعني ما حصلتش
من عشرات السنوات 60 في الميه من
الاسرائيليين بيرفض وبيهدد وبيندر وفي
عمليه عصيان في الجيش وفي مؤسسه كبرى
بتهدد بالخروج ازمه غير مسبوقه ومع ذلك
ويمرض رئيس الوزراوات ولا يوجد قلق ايه
القلق اكثر حاجه يمكن ان تحدث اذا رئيس
الوزراء مرد مات فجاه ان مش هيحصل لها
انقلاب ولا قلق ولا في مشاكل هيجي تاني
هيبقى فيه رئيس وزراء مؤقت من الحزب بتاعه
وممكن تحصل انتخابات او اذا حد يتصعد من
الحزب الفائز في الائتلاف بس
الازمه العنيفه اللي نزلت فيه الشوارع
اللي قطعت بانظمه في الدول العربيه اللي
عندها انظمه اكثر هشاشه اكثر حاجه ممكن
تعملها في اسرائيل ان يتغير رئيس الحكومه
انها تغير الحكومه لكن الدوله تفطر زي
فرنسا
يعني مظاهرات عنيفه جدا اكثر حاجه كانت
ممكن تطيح بالحكومه رئيس الحكومه بوزير ان
شاء الله حتى تجبر الرئيس على الاستقاله
ولكن يبقى النظام وتبقى كل شيء وما فيش
مشاكل لان في مؤسسات ما فيش
يعني انتم ما فيش ان انا بطلع كده بروح
اقول لك انا هحقلب النظام تقلب النظام ليه
ما هو النظام حتى في الصراع ما بين روسيا
وما بين الغرب روسيا بلد عنده مقاومات
دوله كبرى
نقاط ضعفه هو تمركز السلطه في ايدين شخص
واحد فاذا اطيح
او بمن سبقه ممكن يحدث اعتزاز ممكن انما
اذا حدث اطاحه ببيض مثلا ايه اللي هيحصل
ولا اي حاجه هتيجي كامله حارس تبقى الرئيس
مؤقتا بتحصل انتخابات يجي الرئيس اللي جاي
الاداره فشلت للفتره خلصت تكمل الاربع
سنين وخلاص فده
يعني ده احد اسباب قوه الدول اللي هي
استقرت ديمقراطيه درس تاني من اسرائيل
يعني انه دائما الديمقراطيه بيعلموها لنا
في الكتب لازم دوله تبقى مستقره وانما ما
اكونش عندها تهديدات امنيه بالاضافه الى
وضعها الاقتصادي اسرائيل عمرها ما كانت
امنه الى هذا الحد ومع ذلك نجحت من
السنوات الاولى انها تعمل نظام ديمقراطي
ودي حاجه تحتاج الى دراسه
لماذا يترك الغرب اردوغان برغم طموحه
الواضح وتوجهه الاسلامي الذي لا يخفيه علي
دي قصه قديمه وتكلمنا عنها كتيره يا استاذ
علي اولا الكلام ده كان يتسال السؤال في
مراحل
من
2003 ل 2010 و11 اردوغان كان هو
[موسيقى]
اسف يعني هو كان
الزعيم الشرق اوسطتي المحبب لكثير من دول
الغرب باعتباره كان حاجه عظيمه جدا توجد
توبترول جميل جدا الى درجه انه لا يصدق هو
زعيم اسلامي وفي نفس الوقت على علاقه
جميله جدا بكل الدول الغربيه بيقوم بعمليه
كل الامور ماشيه يعني هو زعيم ليبرالي بس
بيحمل رايه اسلاميه ما بيستفزش حد
فكانوا يتمنوا انه يقيموا علاقات معه ولما
يقيموا علاقات معه يقولوا للناس المسلمين
وانه كمان يكون جسر بينهم وبين العالم
الاسلامي من بعد 2011
اربع سنوات تاليه لا مش تلات اربع الحقيقه
لغايه سنتين ثلاثه برضو كان عظيم جدا لانه
هو اراد ان يقود التغيير في الشرق الاوسط
من خلال دعم التيارات الاسلاميه اللي ادى
انطباع جيد جدا للولايات المتحده
والبريطانيا
انا عامل مشاكل معكم قالوا له لا
فساعدوه لكن فشلت
الثورات الربيع العربي وبدا يبقى فيه
مقاومه من الدول اللي موجوده وبدا بيحصل
عنده هو اضطرابات لان في دول بدات تلعب له
كمان في الداخل وبدت العلاقات تضطرب وكل
شيء تغير فالعمليه مرت بمراحل يا صديقي
لدي سؤال
انا اجبت ارجو اكثر من حلقات نعرف اقتصاد
مع الاستاذ هاني ان شاء الله استاذ هاني
صديق يعني جميل واقتصادي ممتاز جدا وطبعا
الراجل لانه المورد العذب كثيره زحام
فعاليه طلب كثير
ويعني عنده مشغوليات كثيره ولكن ان شاء
الله يكون معنا في اقرب فرصه وكمان هيكون
معنا اقتصاديين اخرين ان شاء الله انا
واثق فيه كفائتهم هيكونوا اضافه كبيره
وهيساعدوا فيه باذن الله نشر المعرفه
الاقتصاديه بشكل جيد
يعني هننوع من الضيوف اللي هيشرفونا في
القناه في الفتره اللي جايه الحرب في
السودان اه السيد هل يجب ان يكون مع
اعجبنا هل تابع اجبت
كيف كيف هل يجب كيف هل هل يجب وضع
اللاجئين السودانيين في مصر داخل مخيمات
وهل لهم خطر على مصر بسبب وجودهم داخل
المدن السؤال القاصد يا اخونا انا انا ما
اعرفش انا في مصر يعني طول عمري في مصر ما
عرفش ان مصر حطت الا اذا كانت في حاجه انا
ما اعرفهاش اي لاجئين في مخيمات
اللاجئ بيجي مصر دي من مزايا يعني الوضع
في مصر يعني والحكومات المصريه اللاجئين
بيجوا
بيدخلوا المدن وبيعيشوا ما حصلش انه في لا
لاجئين سوريين ولا سودانيين ولا افارقه من
دول مختلفه بما فيهم اثيوبيا ولا ليبيين
ولا غيره انا يعني
[موسيقى]
مصر بقى فيها عدد مهول من من الضيوف يعني
ولا لاجئين الكثيرين جدا ما حدش عايش في
مخيمات وما اعرفش انه اللاجئين السودانيين
في اي وقت اجمالا شكله مخاطر طبعا احنا ما
بنعش في الجنه قد ياتيك سوداني ولا ليبي
ولا سوري ويرتكب جرائم ولكن هذا امر وارد
يعني
مفيش مشاكل اسمع عن هائله اذا كان هناك ما
لا اعلمه وما لا اعلمه كثير
[موسيقى]
يا اكرم انا شفت سؤالك
اخونا بيقول هل ديون المغرب الخارجيه تشكل
خطر عليه انا اخر مره تابعتك كان ارتفاع
ديون المغرب لمئه مليار دولار وكان هذا
رقما كبيرا يعني هل تشكل خطر عليه الاجابه
تقتضي ان احنا نعرف هيكل الديون يعني قد
ايه من الميه مليار دولار وهو رقم كبير
اذا كنا بنتكلم على ديون خارجيه بالنسبه
للناتج المحلي الاجمالي للمغرب ولكن اهم
من الرقم هو هيكله الديون يعني ممكن تكون
ديون طويله الاجل ممكن تكون جزء منها كبير
عاجل خلال مثلا 23 او 24 فده محتاج ان
احنا ننظر نظره فاحصه اكتر الى الاقتصاد
وهيكلته قد ايه مستحق منه على الدوله
اخونا تركي بيقول لماذا تدير الجزائر
ظهرها الى الغرب وتتجه نحو الشرق وهل
سيكون هناك عواقب لذلك لا هي الجزائر لا
تدير ظهرها الى الغرب بصراحه
الغار المغرب والجزائر اللي هم الدولتين
اللي بيحركهم المنافسه فيما بينهم المغرب
اقرب الى الغرب طول عمرها والجزائر اقرب
الى الشرق طول عمرها ولكن الاتنين الحقيقه
بقوه علاقتهم مع الجانبين ردا على سؤالك
مثلا الجزائر بتوثق علاقتها تماما مثلا
بالصين وروسيا وفي نفس الوقت هي حريصه جدا
ان هي تكون سبلاير او مصدر رئيسي للغاز
على حساب روسيا مثلا
استفدت جدا من الازمه بتحاول رغم ان مصدر
سلاح الاساسي 70 والاكثر من 70% سلاح روسي
ان مبادئ ان هي تحصل على اسلحه من المانيا
ومن
فرنسا بتوثق علاقتها التجاريه رغم ان هي
فرضت عقوبات على اسبانيا علاقتها باسبانيا
بفرنسا وما تقدرش تعمل علاقات ضعيفه مع
بلد مع البلدان دي لان في القرب الجغرافي
وعدد السكان الكبير جدا من الجزائريين عده
ملايين من الجزائريين موجودين في فرنسا
هنا اقرب الى الغرب اقرب الى الصين وروسيا
مش معناها ان هي
يعني تركت الغرب استاذ سيد اجابنا
وبعدين يا عمرو عشان انت موجود النهارده
مش مندو الاسئله المقرره بشكل مرعب المره
دي
عايزاك تجاوب على اسئلتي الفجر بيبعتوها
كذا مره كتير
بشكل باشا عشان عارفين انت ما بتشوفش
الاسئله كتير
عمرو بيقول لي الاسئله المقرره كثير جدا
بسبب حرص اصحابها على الاجابه بس والله لو
انتوا عملتوا السؤال انا كده كده حتى لو
انه الوقت خلص وما جاوبتش احنا ان شاء
الله هننتظم في اللقاء بس تكرار السؤال
بشكل كبير جدا
بيخليني ما اعرفش اجاوب بقيه الاسئله
فاكون رجاء بلاش تكررك اكتر من مره اكون
شاكر جدا ليكم ما لم يكن هناك سبب مهم
يعني
انا محمد
انا عديت حاضر يا محمد هرجع لك حاضر بس
اسئله بسرعه كده
هل حقل ظهر تسرب اليه المياه ويوجد مشاكل
في الغاز المصري ما اعرفش ان حقل
ظهر التسرب اليه مياه او لا دي مشاكل فنيه
بس انا عارف ان في مشكله في قطاع الغاز
وصناعه الغاز في مصر وان شاء الله خلال
هذا الاسبوع المقبل هيكون في حلقه عن وضع
الغزل المصري واسباب انقطاع الكهرباء
ومشكله الغاز المصريه باذن الله خلال
الاسبوع المقبل باذن الله
امريكانجرس هيرنج
اللي احنا كنا نفس السؤال خلاص نشوفه ان
شاء الله بيسالني على
بيقول لي ان في جلسه في الكونجرس النهارده
عن الاجسام الطائره
انا بيسالني عن رايي انا ما شفتوش يعني ما
شفتش الجلسه اشوفها ان شاء الله ولو كان
فيها جديد انا عامل حلقه وانت اكيد
بتسالني عشان الحلقه اللي انا عملتها
الحلقه اللي انا عملتها بفضل الله يعني هي
انا حاولت اركز فيها القضيه من ساعه ما
ظهرت الجديد هيكون راي الكونجرس بقى يعني
ايه يعني
الجهات اللي بيسالوها الاجسام دي جايه
منين واحنا دايما عندنا سؤالين سؤال او
فئتين هل الاجسام ديت جايه من الفضاء
وطبيعتها ايه ولا هي اجسام قادمه من دول
خارجيه ارسلت اي اجسام واحنا مش عارفينها
هو ده دائما التفسيرين يعني الا اذا كان
في تفسير ثلث والعلبه مش عارفة الخبراء
هيتكلم وخلصت اللي هيقولوه ان شاء الله
انقله لكم اذا كان فيه جديد
السعوديه غرقت في المستنقع اليمن وتتودد
لايران لحفظ ماء وجهها طب وليه يا اخونا
عاشق بني عثمان بصيغ المسائل على كده يعني
حتى لو خدت اه طبعا يعني انت بتتكلم
السعوديه نفسها تخرج من اليمن اكيد انما
انت لو هتصغر الوضع ده يعني بناء على انها
هزيمه نفترض انه حد دخل وتورط في حرب
هل يكون يعني انه يسعى انه يخرج منه دي
تبقى هزيمه يعني ايه هو دخل حاول وجد ان
القصه ديت استغرقت سنوات طويله النتائج
للمحاوله بالطريقه ديت لم يؤتي نتائجه
الاسباب اللي بان عليها القرار في 2015
الان لم تعد قائمه الافضل لي ان يخرج
ودائما في كل العلوم في كل الاكاديمات
العسكريه هناك
يعني كورس ثابت للانسحاب من اي اشتباك او
اي مواجهه عسكريه كيف تنسحب وده من
الاساسيات في العلوم العسكريه واكيد في
العلوم السياسيه ازاي انا اخد قرار ثم
ابتدي اتراجع عنه واقلل الخسائر حتى في
الاستثمار يعني
المشكله مش هتبقى عندي السعوديه المشكله
هتبقى عندي اليمنيين لان خروج السعوديه
امر ممكن بالتفاهم مع الحوثيين انما اللي
صعب جدا هو هيعمل ايه اليمنيين فيما بينهم
اذا الاطراف الخارجيه ديت خرجت واثارت
السلامه لنفسها الاطراف اليمنيه دي
هتتفاهم مع بعض ازاي
كيف نجحت تركيا على مر مئات عامل بانشاء
دوله ديمقراطيه نوعا ما بينما فشل العرب
في ذلك سؤال يحتاج الى يعني
حلقات انما احسن ما في سؤالك يا صديقي اذا
اذنت لي يعني وانت تقول ديمقراطيه نوعا ما
والسبب طبعا انه التجربه لانه تركيا لغايه
يعني
الحياه لغايه دلوقتي يعني لو وضعها افضل
شويه يعني اقتصاد اقوى شويه هي دوله حيويه
جدا للنيتو دوله حيويه للاتحاد الاوروبي
رغم ان هي مش عضوي فيه ما يقدروش يتحملوا
ان هي تنهار هي الدوله كمان
يعني
قدرت تستغل موقعها وموقعها الحيوي في انها
تستفيد من الشرق والغرب لكن حكايه
الديمقراطيه ديت ده كان نتيجه هي كانت
لغايه قبل اردوغان ما حدش كان بيتكلم عند
ديمقراطيه
تركيا يعني قبل العشرين سنه انما حتى في
عصر اردوغان الديمقراطيه كان جزء منها
كبير مرتبط برغبتها في الانضمام للاتحاد
الاوروبي كاحد الشروط الاساسيه للاتحاد
الاوروبي لان كان عندها امل فبداوا يفكروا
في ذلك وكمان الراجل بمهارته قدر يقنع او
يضغط او يمنع الجيش من التدخل في الشان
انما ظلت الديمقراطيه زي ما انت قلت الى
حد ما احنا مفيش حافز موجود عندنا وما فيش
تجربه وما فيش اسس تخلينا نقدر ناخده الى
الديمقراطيه دي يعني قبل سنوات طويله اذا
بدا الاصلاح من دلوقتي
فالفرق كبير دي دوله داخل نصها او جزء
كبير منها داخل اوروبا وتطمح ان تكون داخل
الاتحاد الاوروبي وبالتالي كانت ده حافز
لها ان هي تطور ممارستها الديمقراطيه
لماذا الصين لا تدخل ميناء عدن في مشروع
في مشروع طريق الحرير وهل الامارات
يدن في استفاده اليمن من هذا المشروع
الصين تتمنى تدخل وهي بتراقب ما يجري
وموقف الصين من الموقف الصين في اليمن
تقدر ترخصه ان هي عاوزه تبقى لطيفه مع
الكل في انتظار ان المدافع تهدا وبعدين
تدخل في مشروعات بنيه تحتيه ده ردا على
سؤالك يعني وهي حاولت تعمل ده في الفتره
اللي فاتت ومنتظره النتائج الاجواء انما
الامارات هل هتستفيد الامارات لا ممكن
تتضرر اذا نشطت كل طبعا الموانئ اليمانيه
لانه الموانئ اليمنيه عندها مزايا لا
تتوفر فيه الموانئ الاماراتيه وبالتالي
اذا هذه الموانئ تولتها شركات كبيره وبدات
عندها طبعا هتاثر وهتاخد حصه من الموانئ
الاماراتيه
السلام عليكم استاذي العزيز انا من اشد
اعداء
نظريه المؤامره اود ان اسمع وجهه نظرك
وتفسيرك لكيف اندثرت ازمه الكوفيد في لمح
البصر مع بدايه العدوان الروسي على
اوكرانيا شكرا لكم
شوف يا صديقي يعني هو السؤال من محورين
انا هقول لك بقطع النظر بقى عن مساله
عليه هتقتدي انه نتكلم على التفاصيل
بالتفاصيل ديت طبيعه الفيروس الفيروس اصبح
مستوطن الفيروس
فدي قصه يتكلم عليها افضل مني انما ايا
كان الوضع فيما يتعلق بنظريات المؤامره
ديت المساله بسيطه خالص وما اعتقدش انها
محل جدال بين الناس
نظريه المؤامره دي معناها وانا لسه
النهارده كان عندي
ضيف يعني وهذا الضيف او هذه الضيفه
العزيزه من بتؤمن جدا بنظريه المؤامره
وكان هذا النقاش انا طوال الوقت بالمنطقه
ده نظريه المؤامره دي معناها انه في قناعه
عند اصحابها ان هناك من يتامر في مكان ما
وهذا المكان غير معروف ولا توجد دليل على
اجتماعهم لتحقيق مصلحه على حساب الاخرين
ودائما هذه النظريه او هذا الخوف هو خوف
افتراضي لا توجد عليه دليل لانه لو عليه
دليل يبقى خلاص ما فيش مشكله فنظريه
المؤامره بمعنى الخوف من شيء لا وجود
لدليل عليه هو حرف في الهواء يعني يعني
انت لما تيجي تقول كده
يعني اشهر نظريه المؤامره ارتبطت مش
ارتبطت برضو باليهود انه حكماء برتقالات
حكماء بني صهيون ان في مجموعه من اليهود
قاعدين في مكان ما عايزين يسمموا الماء
ويسمموا الهواء
الشعوب ويبوظوا اخلاقها
ده كم يعني دايما لازم يكون في سبب للسلوك
البشري انا بعمل ده ليه اساسا هل انا بس
بجتمع كده واسخر كل قدراتي حتى افسد الكون
انا النهارده نظريه المؤامره اللي انت
بتقول عليها بمعنى فيروس كوفي 19 مين
اطلقه هل مجموعه شركات ادويه مثلا هل
الصين هل الولايات المتحده لدول العالم
كلها تورطت فيه فعلشان تكون في طرف عمله
وما حدش ابدا قدر يضبطه وانه عمل هذا
الفيروس وكان واثق انه العالم يتاثر وهو
لا يتاثر والعالم كله تقريبا تاثر مساله
صعب جدا جدا انه تصدق علشان ما صدعكش
انت الامور التي لا يوجد عليها دليل حاول
تبحث عن دليل عليه اذا عجزت تجاوزها واذهب
الى شيء اخر البشر صعب جدا انه يكون في
مجموعه بتحاول تتامر سرا ومحدش يعرف عنها
حاجه ولا يمكن ابدا ضبطها ونفضل احنا
مصدقين القصه دي الى ابد الابدين يعني
في اسرار الاسرار دي احيانا بتضع علامات
استفهام نضع علامه استفهام ولا ننسق الى
التفسيرات التامراتيه اللي ما فيش دليل
عليها
كيف السيد انس السعودي
ولدي سؤال هل الجغرافيا
الجميله لدوله لدوله المغرب افضل من باقي
دول العربيه
وبماذا تتميز تتميز دوله المغرب ولماذا
تشاهد هجره المصريين وعرب للعيش في المغرب
مش فاهم حكايه المغرب مع اسرائيل لكن انا
الجزء اللي انت اجبت عليه اكرم انت بتتكلم
على جغرافيه المغرب جغرافيه المغرب
جغرافيا بديعه طبعا لانه هي صحيح نقطه
التقاء ما انت لما تيجي تقول هي بتتميز
ايه نقطه التقاء بين اوروبا وما بين
افريقيا بس هذا وحده لا يكفي لانه نقطه
الالتقاء بين اوروبا ينطبق على وافريقيا
تنطبق على الجزائر وتنطبق على تونس وتنطبق
على ليبيا وتنطبق على مصر وهكذا لكن
البديع في موقف مصر والمغرب انه مصر عندها
اطلاله كان المغرب عنده اطلاله كبيره جدا
على المتوسط والمحيط الاطلنطي وبالتالي
يقدر يربط جدا اوروبا بافريقيا بالولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا عبر المحيط الاطلنطي
اطلاله عظيمه جدا على ممرين مائيين بشكل
بديع
فيما يتعلق
بمصر نفس القصه عندها اطلاله على المتوسط
واعطاء اطلاقها على البحر الاحمر فقادر
انها تربه عده قارات بعضها ببعض اضف بقى
الى كده انه الدول اللي هي بتتمتع بمناخ
متوسطي جميل زي المغرب ده بيديها مزايا
كثيره ان هي تكون بلد سياحي
خصوصا بقى بتاريخها القديم بس تاريخ
القديم اللي عندها بيرتبط مع دول اخرى
انما اللي ميز المغرب الحقيقي عن دول اخرى
انه كانت هي مستقره ومفتوحه للثقافات
الاخيره في مقابل دول اخرى في المنطقه ما
كانتش يعني ليبيا مثلا لسنوات طويله وما
زلت حتى الان كان بلد رغم ثراء الا انه
كان صعب جدا يكون جاذب للسياح مثلا
وبالتالي هي الموقع اللي هو متميز
باطلالته على الاتنين الجو المتوسطي
الانفتاح على العالم الخارجي كل ده
والاستقرار النسبي يعني ما فيش اضطرابات
كتير تذكر في المغرب يعني
استاذنا العزيز
الجيش المصري يملك من القوه التي تكفي
لحمايه البلاد لكن عشر سنوات الماضيه
بالغوا في صفقات السلاح تعدت 15 مليار
دولار في دوله تعرف مشاكل اقتصاديه ما
تعليق على ذلك ما عنديش تعليق ده جيش يعني
تتكلم على احتياجات الجيش عاوزه واحد يكون
عسكري ويكون عارف احتياجات الجيش هو كان
وضعه ايه وكان محتاج يتطور قد ايه
بس الرقم اللي انت بتقوله 15 مليار دولار
في عشر سنوات رقم
متواضع يا اخونا مش رقم كبير يعني لماذا
الصين لا تدخل ميناء اجابنه هل هناك
انا هستاذنكم واقف عند الساعه العاشره
والنصف هل هناك عوده
للاعجبناها هل هناك عوده للطيار القومي في
الوطن العربي والحزب الاشتراكي
لا اعلم يعني ما اعرفش انه شيء انت بتتكلم
على حادثه او اتنين انه بتكلم على الحزب
البعثه اظن بتتكلم على بتتكلم على الاردني
يمكن اجابنا قبل كده لكن انا ما اعرفش ان
ده في عوده يعني الدول العربيه الان عندها
مشاكل مشاكل بقاء يعني دول الخليج عاوزه
تنتقل من
من البترول والغاز الدول العربيه زي مصر
عاوزه تخرج من عثرتها دول زي اوضاع اسوا
زي لبنان وزي سوريا وزي اليمن عاوزه بس
تستقر الاول واطرافها تقعد على مائده
المفاوضات فما ظنش انه الوضع ملائم قوي
قوي يعني لنشاط حزبي ينشط فيه حزب على
اخرين
[موسيقى]
انا محمد من وجهه نظرك استاذنا كيف تقيم
الفرق بين الدول الملكيه والاميريه في
المنطقه العربيه وبين الدول العسكريه
المغلقه
بقالب جمهوري
والله الفكره مش في النظام يا محمد
الفكره في يعني ايه التطبيق يعني نظم
الملكيه ما في شك يعني انه ما تنقص قصير
لك ما فيش حاجه بتنجح قد الحاجه اللي نجح
تنجح الاول وتبني على نجاحك يعني انت عندك
النظم اللي ناجحه واللي استقرت اما ان هي
نظم جمهوريه بتنعم بي ديمقراطيه حقيقيه
وبتساءل فيها الحكومات عما تفعل او نظم
الملكيات الدستوريه ان الملك فيها زي
بريطانيا يعني مجرد عامل استقرار ورئيسه
الوزراء هو الفاعل الحقيقي
لكن في حاله ان الجمهوريات تكون جمهوريات
غير ديمقراطيه وانه رئيس الجمهوريه بيعبر
بيعامل على انه ملك وانه الدساتير بتتغير
على طول بتناسب السلطه التنفيذيه وما
تحتاجه وانه البرلمان غير قادر على مسائله
الحكومه او ملكيات مطلقه شموليه الملك
فيها او الامير هو صاحب القرار الاول
والنهائي هنا مش هتفرق الجمهوريه من ملكيه
واذا كانت فيه
انتم ما تخلطوش ما بين استقرار اوضاع مثلا
الدول الخليج كمالكيات او اميرات بالنظام
الحكم هي جزء من القصه هي الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه انه في وفره اقتصاديه الوفره
الاقتصاديه خلت انه الشعوب هذه الدول لا
تثور عليها كما ثار على في مصر وسوريا
وليبيا واليمن بالاضافه الى ان هذا الثراء
جعل دول العالم الكبيره تستثمر في استقرار
هذه الدول فليس النظام ولكن تطبيقه اذا
كانت المساله فيها ديكتاتوريه والبلد مش
قادره ان هي تقدر تطور في نظم الحكم مش
هيفرق ملكيه من جمهوريه
يعني بلاش انت بتتكلم عملت تتكلم على
الدول الخليج وبتتكلم على مصر انت عندك
بلد زي لبنان اللي كان فيه حراك سياسي
عندك رئيس البرلمان موجود انا موعاش على
رئيس برلمان اخر يعني
انا اسف الاسم طائر من ذهني يعني
هل سيؤثر مشروخ خطي ايلات عسقلان على مر
قناه السويس وماذا تتوقع الرد المصري لا
اتوقع انه يؤثر على ممر قناه السويس اذا
نفض وانه التنفيذ لو نفذ هيكون واحد من
المشروعات الكتيره زي بين الفاء وغيرها
وزي الطريق اللي بتعمله روسيا
وازاي الطريق اللي بتعمله ايران كلها وطرق
بتحاول تربط الشرق بالغرب اجمالا كل الطرق
ديت هتبقى خصما من قناه السويس اذا ظلت
قناه السويس ممر فقط للعبور اما لو اتطور
مشروع قناه السويس كما هو مخطط له وانه
اصبح بيقدم خدمات اكثر من مجرد العبور
هيبقى التاثير اقل بالكثير
طيب معلش ارجع كده من الاخر لانه خرج مني
ما هي قراءته ده اخونا مروك ما هي قراءتك
للاعتراف الاسرائيلي ده سؤال مهم مش
معناها ان الاسئله التانيه ما كانتش مهمه
بقول ما هي قراءتك للاعتراف الاسرائيلي
بالصحراء المغربيه
والله دي قصه انا كنت عاوز اكلمها في حلقه
يعني ولكن الاحداث يعني دايما اقول لكم
بتبقى عندي الحلقه في الظروف الركود الصيف
يعني ولكن
الاسرائيل لما تم عمليه التطبيع ما بين
المغرب واسرائيل
بالوساطه الامريكيه في ديسمبر 2020 كان
اهم طلب للمغرب هو انه امريكا الاول تعترف
بسياده الصحراء على المغرب وقد فعلها
ترامب ملحوظه هو فعلها مش رسميا او داعش
الاعتراف مثلا في الامم المتحده لانده
هيبقى صعب جدا لانه قانونا لا يجوز هذا
الامم المتحده بتقول ان هذه ارض غير
مغربيه
ولكن كان بيعتبره الولايات المتحده هتعترف
فهيكون تحمل قيمه قانونيه او هم دوله في
العالم لكن اهم دوله في العالم تقدر تؤثر
ولكن مش هتغير الوضع
مثلا الولايات المتحده ايام اعترفت بسيره
اسرائيل على مرتفعات الجولان وده لم يغير
من الوضع القانوني لها كانوا للمتوقع ايضا
ان اسرائيل تعترف بالسياده المغربيه على
الصحراء ولكن كانت
الاسرائيل متلكئه عاوزه الاول اولا هي
متلكاه لاسباب بطول شرحها يعني هي كانت
خايفه اعترفت بذلك ده هيوتر علاقتها مع
دول الاتحاد الافريقي التي تعترف
بالجمهوريه الصحراويه هيزيد توترها مع مع
الجزائر مع دول زي جنوب افريقيا وهي
لتتمنى ان كلها موطئ قدم في الاتحاد
الافريقي ولكن كانت تتمنى ان هي تتبع مع
المغرب ولا تعترف بالصحراء يعني تاخذ عرب
الشام وبلح اليمن ولا العكس مش يعني
تستفيد من الجهتين المغرب كان مصرا اصرارا
شديدا على انه لا تحريك لعمليه التطبيع
معها ورفع التمثيل من مكتب رفع العلاقات
من مكتب تمثيل الى
هل فعلا لحظه
احنا الاسئله قالت كثيرا
مساء الخير استاذ سيد اتمنى ان تكون
الحلقه ان تكون الحلقه خاصه عن قضيه
الاوكرانيه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط حلقه
جديده القضيه الكرديه وتاثيراتها في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط في اسرع وقت تسمح بظروف ان
شاء الله هل فعلا زي ما الدكتوره ما صبح
قالت انه في منتصف القطب الجنوبي يمنع
الاقتراب منه هل تعتقد في اسرار لا اعرف
عوافر الاحترام
الدكتوره مايا صبحي معرفهاش وما اعرفش هي
قالت ايه وما اعرفش حاجه على الموضوع
كيف تصل الدول العربيه لحكم جمهوري
ديمقراطي حقيقي دي عاوزه يعني
حلقه احنا كنا عملنا حلقه هل الدول
العربيه
يعني جاهزه وكان المفروض نستانفها بس
النوع ده من الحلقات الحقيقه يعني بصراحه
انا بكلمكم يعني بيبقى مرهج جدا وهي لا
تلقى اهتمام كبير يعني هو طبعا بيلقى
اهتمام من النخب بس عاده يعني النوع ده من
الحلقات
ردود الفعل مش بتشجعني قوي ان انا استانف
فيه لكن حاضر يعني
وهي عموما انا انصحك بكتاب انا رشحته لكم
قبل كده اكتبوا كتاب الدكتور علي الدين
هلال والديمقراطيه انا مش فاكر اسم الكتاب
بس لو كتبت الدكتور علي الدين هلال وهو
باللغه العربيه ومتاح على النت ومتاحها
هيديكم كتاب صغير ولكن بيجيب على هذا
السؤال
وفي كمان اهم بقى يعني بالاضافه الى ما
جاء في الكتاب في مراجع هائله لمن يريد ان
يستزيد داخل الكتاب
انا استاذنكم ناخد السؤال الاخير نبيه بري
استاذ خالد الله يخليك سامحني معلش طبعا
سياسي كبير انا كنت باعتبره رئيس البرلمان
اللبناني ولكن يمكن مع الاجهاد ذاكره ما
تبقاش عظيمه هل تؤذلوني بسؤال الاخير
هل الصين تؤثر على ايران وعلاقتها مع
الخليج لا صعب يا صديقي
هل يوجد هويه هل يوجد هويه لدوله هي الخوف
لم افهم السؤال يا استاذ احمد
طيب انا عارف ان في اسئله كثيره رئيس
البرلمان نبيه بري شكرا جزيلا نبيه بري
نبيه
كثر خيركم انا اجبت على عدد كبير من
الاسئله وعارف انه شكرا يا شباب والله ما
اتحرمش منكم كله صوب على طول نبيه بر نبيه
بالري حاضر وان شاء الله ان شاء الله باذن
الله استاذنكم بقف عند هذا الحد
ونستانف الاربعاء المقبل اربع المقبل عمرو
ممكن مش كده وان شاء الله يكون عمرو معانا
لان ماندو قاعد على الشواطئ البحر المتوسط
هناك بينعم
بندق عليه عمرو بيقول لكن انا وعمري هنا
احنا من الدهماء قاعدين في حر القاهره ان
شاء الله يكون عندنا حلقه لقاء الاربعاء
المقبل باذن الله واللي ما اجرتش يسامحني
وهنجاوبه ان شاء الله اذا كنت اعرف اجابته
الاسبوع المقبل
شكرا جزيلا لكم والقاكم على خير الاربعاء
المقبل باذن الله الى اللقاء